hello
nasa leo
lance
thanks no problem stick together and
let's do this
is this a disco
this i do not like
[Music]
what if we open the doors and run
just run no stopping no shooting just
straight to the bridge
[Music]
[Applause]
heavy really we call them tanks i call
them brutes
from latin brutus we'd sound smart
calling them fruits
gion you don't want to get in here and
help name these nah i'm good
the anacrusis is looking like a game i
didn't realize i needed in my life
and here from stray bombay to tell us
more about the anacrusis
it's chet felicek thank you for being
here oh thanks for having me
now talk to me about this game the
anacrusis
what's the concept how did you come up
with this so i grew up with
late 60s early 70s sci-fi i love that
stuff right logan's run
uh you know battlestar galactica space
1999 that wasn't cheesy to me
or campy that was just the way sci-fi
was so we wanted to set a game in that
world
right we have those cool colors cool
shapes fantastical sci-fi weapons and
creatures
and then it also lends itself to we
wanted something that was positive about
the players the characters
you're working together sure there's
aliens sure you're fighting them sure
you're trying to save earth
but you're doing it in a positive
uplifting way yeah i just after the
pandemic i don't think i could go back
to dreary post
apocalyptic world i need something
uplifting so we wanted to deliver that
that that's awesome now talk to me about
the game play you
you've said that there's an infinite
replayability to this so so how does
that factor in
yeah so there's four player co-ops
you're playing with your friends
and what we all want to do is make sure
that it's different every time you're
playing it and so we have a lot of
different systems that do that but
underneath it all is the idea of the ai
driver the ai driver is driving
everything that's happening in the game
with items where they're placed what's
happening with the creatures what's
happening
with your health kits your perks all
those systems are driven off of that
and so what that means is as you're
playing not only do you have those
hey this last time we played this there
was nothing here and this time we're
being overwhelmed
yeah and then you also have those peaks
and valleys so that you have some
downtime and you have some
really big uptime in it or you know a
lot of combat happening in it we're also
monitoring how people are playing so
it's if your first time playing and your
team isn't doing very well
we'll put health kits right on the main
path for you to find then if you don't
find them
at first we'll we'll spawn a couple more
later if you're really good if you're
really killing it
well we might not put anything on the
main path and so if you want to go find
your perks or if you want to go find new
weapons you have to go off that main
path
and go search for that it makes the game
just a little bit harder but in a way
more interesting way than just saying
hey let's double the health of all the
enterprises right
and then we do something else we
actually look from session to session as
well
so if you play with the same three
friends every week you guys been killing
it for 10 weeks in a row
well let's mix it up for you let's just
throw something crazy at you that you've
never seen before in a million aliens
we can do that because you normally when
you do difficulty you've got to be here
because you don't know what happened
before or after but here
we have these really big peaks and
valleys so we can bring you to nothing
for a little bit
and then have you have it go crazy i
love that it's it's scaling to to your
basically your your skill level
right so yeah that's fantastic now kind
of deeper dive more into the perk system
that you're going to have in the game
so for the perks we looked at a lot of
games where you start with
um let's say a class based thing and
then you know if you're playing with
your same friends
well i'm going to be support you're
going to be carrie
someone else may have like we kind of
get into a rut of what systems we're
playing and how we're playing
so we want to be able to mix that up so
that every time you're playing you're
also
kind of choosing your role based on the
perks you're getting so perks come in
this
thing called the mata compiler you have
to go find the meta compilers in the
world and once you find one
you'll have from one to three perks to
choose from then over time you're
essentially
building a deck for your for your
character and so you might have it where
if you saw in the trailer there's a
pulse
which is kind of like a melee shove well
you can invest into that and you can
have one that you can now
recharge your pulse faster and now it
protects your
other players around you and then it
gets more powerful and you can actually
do damage with it so all of a sudden
you went from being a support character
playing in the back to leading the
charge going forward and knocking down
aliens and everyone else blasting them
or
you'll get a bunch of perks that are
about um investing in one weapon and
making it where
when you do head shots it actually does
damage other aliens around so now you're
the sniper hanging back
and so it's really mixing up that kind
of experience that you're having and
you'll earn these perks as you play so
the more you play the more perks you
have
but since we want the game to always be
great to play with your friends
if you if you've been playing you know i
will say you play with me i've been
playing 400 hours
you're brand new yeah well we share the
perks so you get all the perks that i
have available to me as well so that way
you could have that experience of all
that craziness in your game as well
because it's all about having fun with
your friends right the shared experience
with your friends now we kind of already
talked about the inspirations like like
2000
i looked at that and it was like 2001
space odyssey was the first thing i
thought of but
let's talk more about the enemies in the
game what was some of the inspirations
for that
so the enemies um is we kind of look at
it of how we want the players to behave
as well as feel and so we bring in
outside play testers every week
they play our game we watch them and
what we'd see is really good teams would
stick together
really tightly and even if we send
something like the brood at them that
spreads them apart they quickly form
back together
so we created something called the
spawner yeah and this is a good example
of kind of how we approach
the design the spawner you hear off the
distance
and you'll hear it and you know what
it's doing it's spawning things it
spawns these little turrets that come at
you they're not the worst
thing but they're going to be
unrelenting until you kill the spawner
and so you'll be sticking with your team
and you'll be like oh wait a minute if
the spawner comes now and there's
turrets come and we've got a guy down
we've got to go over there i'm not
sticking with my team i'm gonna go hunt
that thing down and
go kill it so you go run off you kill it
you're feeling good about it and also
you realize wait where are my teammates
i'm all alone there's other specials
here oh i'm in trouble and it's trying
to create those kind of moments where
it's mixing it up
where you always want to have it where
it kind of almost takes turns of one
player's the last one surviving they're
the last one up and they're helping
everybody else up and get it going and
so
really looking at having those enemies
give you those moments by how it affects
the players
bonus question for you what does the
anacrusis actually mean
so anachrosis is a musical term it means
the
the notes before the song the little the
little kind of intro
and for this we have a character boris
that you never meet
um and then all the parallels just talk
about it because it was fun to have this
character that you never really
are sure who they are because everyone
else describing it
and she uh named the barge that you're
on that you're launching these missions
to anacrusis
and her thought there was this is not
the main event this is not
us against the aliens with fighter
pilots and everything else it's just
regular people
this is the pre-battle to the battle
this is finding out about these aliens
and what just happened
oh that that sounds so cool again the
anna cruz
everything that you talked about today
it sounds amazing i can't wait to get my
hands on it but
chet thank you so much for being here i
really appreciate it thanks for having
me
we've got so much